Oh, man.
A PS2?
How y’all still got an active
working PS2?
That's what I'm saying.
I'm Miles Sanders, Running Back.
I’m Micah Parsons, linebacker, rusher.
We representing the Ring of Honor.
And we bringing in players.
Tony G. Randy. Barry Sanders.
Prime Time, L.T. now that's cool.
So right now, we playin’ Madden ‘98.
I wasn't even born yet.
I was only one years old.
The Lions are terrible.
Man, I don’t even know how to kick.
Or is you kicking?
Nah, that’s you.
Oh, wow. Oh, wow.
You gotta look at Barry Sanders,
see all the stuff that he used to
do to these boys back then.
The way he runs
the ball is very... dang.
I don't think I’m running.
You’re supposed to use this.
I keep going backwards.
Yeah, his running style is very unique.
Yeah, I’m getting the
hang of this game.
How do you throw the ball, man?
This is stressing me out y’all.
Yeah, that was some
Micah Parsons stuff right there.
I’m flustered right now, guys.
Go, Emmitt.
Go, Emmitt!
Ain’t no way.
What’d I say?
Are you serious?
Oh, we could transition.
Oh, now you wanna transition?
Now we in ’04, Madden ’04.
Vikings versus Falcons.
My dad was actually huge in Madden.
They used to have Madden
tournament's with him and his friends.
Yep. Thank you.
Thank you!
We gotta try to get
the ball to Randy.
Yep, Randy.
Randy.
What defender
do you think could have done
the best job against Randy?
Prime.
Prime, yeah.
There’s no one who’s
going to match his speed.
They say Prime and Randy,
if they clocked them
like how they clock
today… they would have ran
like a 4.1.
Better lock in, bro.
That was your first
touchdown in how long?
You better lock in, brother.
I’m playing Ultimate Team.
Madden Ultimate Team could be
the number one best thing about Madden.
The thing I like about it
you get to sell the players
you don’t want, buy someone new.
You have seasons almost like franchise.
You can buy packs to unlock
people, which is pretty cool.
Get that block. Tony G! Tony G!
Stiff arm. Yep! Get off me.
Hey Miles,
If you had to pick a
receiver of all time…
There's some cold receivers
now, that I really like.
Yes sir, Randy.
Randy, for sure.
But other than Randy? Davante Adams.
Yeah this is night
and day from Madden ’98.
Night and day.
Oh my God.
Let me show y’all
something with Barry Sanders.
This is the best play in the game.
Halfback counter. Watch the blocking.
You let them set up… Yep. Yep.
If you had to pick your
Ring of Honor players...
Not putting yourself in there?
Oh I thought we was just doing legends.
Of course I’ll put myself in there.
With that five right there,
I think we could beat y’all.
I think the only matchup
that's going to be legit
is going to be that DB
and receiver matchup.
Yeah, we got Revis and Prime Time.
But I got Randy...
and we got prime time.
I got Randy. We got Prime.
I got Randy, my guy.